haven't done the video in a few days I'm
sorry about that guys I didn't know what
to do a video on I wanted to do a video
for you guys and then I saw a really
cool show so we're gonna talk about that
[Music]
homeland yeah as in like security I so
homeland is on Showtime the same station
that shows Dexter and we all love serial
killers and we all love you know 24 and
homelands produced by a couple of the
guys who produced 24 so like all right
homeland security 24 it's gonna be all
cool and you know homeland security is
sure we're gonna go out there and we're
gonna fight her
our first thing to know is it's not
really like 24 meet 24 was like Jack
Bauer and guns and Tina Stanley this
really doesn't have guns it's all the
information and espionage aspects of
that kind of thing those eyes and ears
in every room you know keeping tabs on
people one guy in particular and that is
the guy who played dick winters and Band
of Brothers hero so this guy was a POWs
in the Middle East he just got rescued
so now he's coming home after like five
years and everyone's all pumped and
happy except Claire Danes who's
convinced that there's a US soldier
somewhere who has been turned against
the United States it's gonna be put back
in the United States it's like a sleeper
and she's like all right it's dick
winter so I'm keeping tabs on this guy
but you don't really know if he's a
sleeper and I mean he could be but
you're like is he it's dick winners from
Band of Brothers they wouldn't do that
to us or would they and I really found
this show interesting we first of all
Claire Danes I don't know much about
Claire Danes I see Claire Danes once
every like eight years all in all though
she's really good she plays her role
well and there's one thing you can take
away from the show for nothing else you
learn [ __ ] be crazy see the show
you'll know what I'm talking about
everyone has secrets in the show and she
has secrets too she's kind of this
problem child and the agency they're all
like we don't want you to get too
involved because you're a pain in the
ass which is pretty cliche for a show
like this but yeah it works
then there's I don't know the dudes name
I suck with names dick winters from
bandits this guy is a really good actor
if you've never seen Band of Brothers
watch Band of Brothers I should do a
video on Band of Brothers
I just might one day if you don't know
I'm from Band of Brothers he's Jonesy
from dreamcatcher but we won't hold that
against him but the dudes a good actor
he plays the role really well I mean
he's back from being a powa know so he's
kind of shaky he's nervous in crowds but
the whole time you're like has he turned
against the United States that's all I
want to know and you know they're not
gonna spoil that question for you in the
pilot episode which is all I've seen so
far which is all this aired so far but
they give me just enough to be like he
just might have
he might have I don't know though and
he's married to an arrow from Firefly
which hit you see her naked in a sex
scene in this show so for all you people
out there who have been like for the
last 10 years I've wanted to see Inara
naked and maybe even in a sex scene you
feel like the universe slapped you in
the face when she cut her hair for V the
universe makes it up to you now so
congratulations you're welcome show time
for getting all my subscribers to watch
homeland I take payment in the form of
cash credit card PayPal and maybe more
scenes like that with Inara
and homeland but hey information
espionage betrayal dick winters from
Band of Brothers on Showtime so you know
it's like a movie the premise is really
cool there's gonna be some crazies out
there gonna be like it's anti-american
propaganda it's teaching that the men
and women and the heroes that come on
from being a powr now against the United
States just anti murder no it's just
called good TV so just roll with it dude
my question is though with a premise
like this how long can they keep the
show going it's like a 12 episodes
season and you have to know by the end
of the twelve episodes season if he is
or is not treasonous after that where do
they go so is it like a one season thing
I don't know in the end I say check this
show out it's really cool it gave you
enough in the end to be like this is
exactly why I need to tune in next week
yeah tune in I talk like him from the
six days yes see terranova that's how
you hook the audience
it's like 24 with no guns meets no way
out with Kevin Costner yeah that's it so
there are a lot of new shows a lot of
cool shows it is pilot season of the new
shows what are your favorite comment
below let me know in any case check out
homeland if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]